how are you LT I'm doing wonderful rich
how can I not be after last night I mean
it's unbelievable how do they do it
LT let's just start with the macro
question well I think you know I think
there's many layers to how they did it
you know I think the thing that stands
out to me the most is is one like this
team has really been starting to really
connect over the last you know two years
now it started with the run from late
last season remember rich they started
on for new culture staff you know all
that stuff but you're seeing a team
that's very comfortable with each other
now and they simply are well balanced
they know how to win games now he's a
bond defense plan so well about Philip
Rivers caring this team all these
receivers are Melvin Gordon's running
the football and to me you know I think
it's really a reflection of the head
coach the way he has built his team now
yes he does have fantastic coordinators
guys that have been here coaches before
can and Gus
so they play a tremendous part in this
but I think that's the reason why just
he and his team starting to play so well
and then what does Phillip do in the
huddle walk me through what what he's
like in these situations from your
obviously recollection as well as from
what you know from the current players
well he you know Philip is a coach out
there on the field so when he calls the
play he just doesn't call the play if
you know what I mean he calls the play
but at the same time he's giving guys
tips you know like last night I'm sure
he told Travis Benjamin in the huddle
all right expect two men two men while
here Travis I got to come to you it's
gonna be open expect a football just
those little tidbits right there that
guys know all right I got to get ready
to make a play he's a coach on the field
and you know you never feel like you're
out of a game with Dillon because he's
always communicating and he's always
making you believe as a teammate - hey
guys we have a chance you know we got a
chance we go down school right here we
got to stop we're gonna go back and
score again and we're gonna win the game
that's that's his approach LaDainian
Tomlinson Pro Football Hall of Famer
here on the Rich Eisen show and Anthony
Lynn you mentioned about what what type
of head coach is he I mean what have we
learned about him over the last couple
of years that you could put a little bit
more dressing on what you said about him
specifically so rich was you know when I
went to New York
Anthony lamb was the running backs coach
and I got to tell you from the first
time I met the man I you know he had
great leadership skills from from the
beginning the way he explained you know
plays the way he talked the running
backs the way he coached him you know he
was always able to coach everybody no
matter if you're a superstar or you're
you know the last man on the depth chart
it doesn't matter to him and I see those
same qualities when he's coaching his
football team he's cultured every aspect
of it it doesn't matter who you are he's
gonna he's going to make sure you do it
a certain way and then the
decision-making you know that's what
stands out to me just last night
he's going for - being aggressive when
he knows he had the opportunity to be
aggressive and then being smart when you
need to be smart when you need to rely
on your defenses say nah let's party the
way
here that's good a stop and then you
know save one time out and so we're
having it up in a in our back pocket so
those decisions man being made by young
hair color it's pretty impressed well
and you may have to go on the road in
January a couple of times too because
the fact still remains that the Chiefs
have destiny control right now for their
final two what are you what do you think
about the Chiefs having eyeballed them
you saw what happened against the Ravens
last week where they needed overtime to
pull it out
they blow this up two touchdown lead
that they held three different times
what do you what do you think of the
Kansas City Chiefs moving forward here
LT I think what we're seeing is you know
obviously what we felt the entire year
that the deep is it Achilles heel for
this team and Patrick mahomes has had to
live with the pressure of scoring so
many points every game because he knows
his defense is gonna give up horns now I
believe last night that team played a
lot different with Eric Berry in the
game the second half and you you know we
saw that things change dramatically in
the second half so depending on Eric
Berry just helped situation you know if
he's not in there I think we're going to
continue to see a defense that struggles
on the back end especially yes they're
very talented up front but the fact of
the matter is those guys are fun rich
they tend to get tired you know and they
can trust like that the whole game
that's why you saw for sex in the first
half and you know it was a drop-off
obviously in the second half because
those guys get tired and so I think
that's gonna be the telltale with the
Chiefs now their office is going to
score they're gonna score against
everybody yeah you know Patrick mahomes
is so talented with those receivers that
they're going to move the ball of school
Florence it's going to be on their
defense to really bring them home like
they say one neighbor to do last night
so do you think that they're vulnerable
I mean what-what do you think happens
when it's all said and done when the AFC
shakes out based on what you've seen
through 14 now plus one game weeks well
I think they're they're very vulnerable
I really do believe that I think there
is really you know number teams honestly
in the AFC that I can just picture going
to Arrowhead and giving that team
problems you just look at the last two
teams that went to Arrowhead Baltimore
and the charges and Baltimore should
have won that game so you mean to tell
me if Baltimore has to go back there in
the playoffs they can't land there the
same with the charges they now believe
that they can go to Arrowhead and win as
well as the Patriots the Patriots beat
them earlier in the year so I gotta
believe that the pages believe that can
go to their head
who knows maybe Pittsburgh if they
happen to get in with all that talent so
I think there are a number of teams rich
that you know they're not afraid of
going to Arrowhead a get plan against
that defense who do you think wins
Patriots Steelers then LT now that we're
looking over the steering wheel for the
rest of the weekend yeah I think you
know if the Steelers don't show an
ability to adjust their game plan when
they play the Patriots then I'll just
see the same old story because it you
know it's mind-boggling to me that still
is every time they play the Patriots
they put their linebackers in zone and
they let the Patriots have everything
underneath Julian element you know grogg
those guys go crazy because everything
is under Neath the paper still is just
let you have it you know so I think if
they don't change that game plan they're
not gonna win this game you gotta get
aggressive with the Patriots and I'm not
so sure that the Steelers defense had
that ability to get aggressive with it
with an offense so our poll question
asked ative LaDainian Tomlinson as we
send him on into the day Chris yeah
who's the MVP frontrunner entering this
week mahomes breeze rivers Gurley what
do you think
well I'll tell you man it I feel I still
think obviously been a former MVP I
think it's still Patrick my homes in a
tight race right now
and the only reason why I say that guys
is because the man still has what 45
touchdown yes sir he's gonna get 250
okay he's gonna get 250 and then the
other thing is you gotta take into
account he hasn't had a defense that can
stop anybody you know he has to play
with the pressure putting up points
every single game and he has and he
hasn't had a bad game so far so you know
I think it's my homes right now in the
tight race but I'll tell you man Phillip
Rivers is gaining ground in my opinion I
think breathe just feel second right now
a close second but Phillip is gaining
ground
I'm telling his his his his personality
and his energy is just infectious it
really is
it's got it it's got to affect everybody
around him LT it really does this is not
you know something you know I know that
you know the public people get to see
this stuff on TV man but this is
everyday was Phyllis you know rich we
used to play dominoes in the locker room
and the first one to sit down at the
table is always Philip Rivers and then
I'm telling you he's playing bones he's
talking trash you know that's who he is
everything he does whether it's
basketball playing dominoes football he
really wants to kick your butt he's that
big of a competitor and it really comes
down you know when he's competing but
he's fun to play with at the same time
it is infectious LT really appreciate
you calling in man travel safe wherever
you're traveling to right now and I look
forward to seeing you at the shop at the
NFL Network in short order
you got rich thank you ma'am you got
always a pleasure right back at your Pro
Football Hall of Famer LaDainian
Tomlinson you can catch him with prime
and Shannon Sharpe and charissa Thompson
every single Sunday night on on gameday
prime the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience